- [Mark] All right, so
Amber, you're back again.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] But something
happened last night, right?
- Yeah.
I said that I did cut down
my dating dramatically,
but sometimes you gotta eat.
This morning I was a little short on rent
so I had to get some rent money,
so I decided to go out there.
Put on my best skippys (laughs)
and I go and I wait.
Doesn't take any time at all,
I get picked up by someone.
Seemed cool.
Talkin', talkin', talkin'.
Not too many red flags.
Then we got to the spot,
"hop in the back."
Okay.
Stepped out of the car,
I'm waiting, I'm waiting, I'm waiting,
he goes 'round this side
of the car to the back door
and he opens the back door
and he says immediately he
just wants me to go to town.
(mumbles) thing out.
And I'm like "oh, yo, I need my bread."
And then he goes, "what?"
And he goes in his pocket
and pulls out something
and sprays it in my face (psh sound)
I've been sprayed in
the face before by mace,
this was not mace.
This was something totally different,
it was like an aerosol.
So it hit me here and just
hit me like (psh sound)
So immediately I'm like
whoa, okay, this is going bad
but I'm thinking we had
such a cool conversation
maybe I could shit talk him
like all the other ones.
"Damn, what's up with that?"
"Why are you doing that shit?"
"What's the big deal?"
"You want a date, no problem with a date."
"Get in my car, bitch."
Sprays me again.
Now, the second time it's
burning more than the first.
Now I know I'm in trouble.
Started trying to get out
of this backset or whatever,
go to that door.
No handle.
So I made a deal with him.
You let me go, I'll give you some pussy.
"Oh, you're gonna give me that anyway."
So did what I thought I
needed to do to get out.
Sprayed me again (psh sound)
"Now give me your money, bitch."
"What money?"
"I don't have any money,
that's why I came outside."
(pow sound) one punch.
Threw me out of the truck.
"Give me your money."
Now, remind you, I'm wearing
clothes that are see through.
You see that I have nothing
other than my outfit on.
I have nothing.
Shoes are in the front seat of his car.
I don't have nothing, I keep telling him
about I haven't made the money, sir.
Kept saying sir because this
kid had a Southern accent,
he had Southern charm.
So I tried to charm him right back, sir.
Didn't work.
When I came to, my face was in the gravel.
There was blood all over the place
and I just wanted to get away
from there as fast as I could.
- [Mark] So when did this happen?
- (laughs) earlier this morning.
Like 5:00 this morning or so.
5:00 or 6:00.
Wasn't light, so I was thinking
about 5:00 in the morning.
- [Mark] Still dark.
That happened in Figureoa?
- Definitely happened on Fig.
Definitely happens, it's
one of those things.
The bad with the good.
- [Mark] So he knocked you out?
- Had to.
I don't know what he did.
I don't know if it was
the stuff he sprayed on me
or the punches I took to the head.
I don't know.
Can't remember everything
but I just remember when I came to,
my face was in the gravel
and I was way far away
from his car.
So I don't even know how I got there.
I'm hoping I ran, not drug.
- [Mark] So you have a black eye?
- Oh, I can't even see out of my eye.
But not just a black eye,
I got a black spirit.
I knew I shouldn't have been there.
I knew but once again-
- [Mark] Your teeth are okay?
Your teeth are okay?
- Oh no, I got two new broken teeth.
- [Mark] And a fat lip?
- Fat lip.
Have a fat lip.
This from here over, I feel
like I got hit by a truck.
- [Mark] Yeah.
The left side of your face is messed up.
- Here over I can see but I can't see
because of whatever he sprayed my face.
It still burns.
Still burning.
So once again, like I
said, it's a work hazard.
It goes with the job, right?
But today, this one, this time, Mark,
not okay.
Really, really not okay.
So I'm doing it.
Legally, imma go to the police
station when I leave here,
and I'll do whatever I can.
It's late but I'm givin' them
whatever information I can
'cause I don't want another
girl to wake up or not wake up
because of this guy or because
I didn't make an effort
to tell anybody.
Not okay and I'd hate to see someone else
have to go through this.
- [Mark] So not that this is about race,
but just so that people will
know who we're dealing with,
it's, what race?
- Oh, it was a young, black,
African American male, young.
- [Mark] With a Southern accent?
- With a Southern accent.
He said he was Alabama.
Mentioned that he was 30 years old.
Has a truck that makes a lot
of noise, like (rattling sound)
- [Mark] Wow.
- He says also, because
I had met him before
and I was supposed to
date him but I didn't,
so when I saw him again
it was like familiarity.
Hey!
'Cause he says, "Can I lick your ass?"
Sure, whatever, dude,
it's your money, though.
But maybe that one thing, that one phrase,
can I lick your ass?
May be the one thing that someone hears
or that one thing about
his Southern accent
or his age, anything I can get out there
so girls in Southern California can know
there's a creepy one out there
and other creeps out there.
- [Mark] This has happened to you before?
- Yeah.
This is the worst though.
I've never really walked
away hurt like this.
That's why I thought it
was always no big deal.
But the disfigurement I saw in the mirror
and the way my spirit
feels, this is way beyond
this is not okay and I'm mad
and imma do something about it.
- [Mark] Who are you
mad at, him or yourself?
- I'm mad at myself but
that's a daily anger,
I'm always mad at myself.
I'm mad at him because he
could've just asked me,
he didn't have to physically harm me.
I didn't have anything.
Shit, I would've came up with something.
My shoes are worth $200,
take 'em, sell 'em,
they're brand new, I just
wore 'em or something.
Something.
Let me help you (mumbles)
I'll give you a couple bucks.
I've done that before.
I had a guy put a 9 millimeter to my head
and I was able to talk that
9 millimeter all the way down
and convince him that you look too good,
you don't have to rape me.
Any time you want to rape
some girl here you call me,
because I'll give it to you,
you're fuckin' fine as hell.
So like I said, this is
not okay and I'm mad.
- [Mark] And if you go to the police,
will you get in trouble?
- Probably so.
Probably so because admitting what I do,
admitting where I stay,
just admitting things,
probably wouldn't be the best for me.
I believe I'm gonna get in trouble.
I believe that there's
gonna be consequences for me
but it's okay, I've had a nice life.
Had an okay life.
Now I look my age but that's okay.
Just be careful, girls.
And parents and people
that have kids out there,
it all starts at childhood.
All this trauma begins
when you're a small kid.
Watch the kids, you
gotta protect the kids.
Gotta be there for the kids
because I was once a kid,
inside I still feel like
that 13 year old kid,
kind of live my life reckless
like that 13 year old kid.
But maybe if somebody
protected this 13 year old kid,
shit, I could've been a
congressman or something.
There's a lot of people
out there like that.
But, can't do nothin'
about us, but the kids,
watch your kids.
People, watch who you
sending your kids off with.
Watch out.
Watch and protect the kids,
that's all I could ask you to do.
(sniffling)
- [Mark] How many times
has this happened to you?
- 10 years.
Average four times, thank you,
average six to eight times a year.
That's how many times it's happened.
Yeah.
- [Mark] Does this make you
wanna consider totally stopping?
- Yeah, so I have one
pair, still have one pair,
they went in the trashcan this morning.
All the clothes that are
associated with that lifestyle
went in the trashcan this morning.
If you see me out there on sidewalk,
it's because I'm walkin' to my car.
Amber no longer exists.
My name's April.
And from this day forward,
I'm gonna be April.
- [Mark] Good for you.
(sniffling)
I'm glad you weren't hurt any worse.
It's horrible but it
could've been a lot worse.
- Yeah, it could've been a lot worse.
- [Mark] Maybe this is what gets you out.
- Right, and thank God
school is online (laughs)
Courses are online, thank God.
- [Mark] Thank you for calling me
with some horrible news (laughs)
- Thank you.
I just wanted to make
sure it got out there,
to share that story.
- [Mark] I'm glad you're okay.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Okay, thank you.
- (mumbled)
(laughing)